Hello, I'm Brian Poole.
I'm the Technical Program Manager at Epic Games,
and I'm here to talk to you today about camera configuration
for ICDFX.
Let's take a look at our slide deck here and our training
outline.
So we're going to go over hardware configuration, where
we'll talk about camera choices, sensor types
and sizes, Unreal film back settings,
building your own camera rig, and how we connect
the camera to the system.
Then we'll move in and talk about SDI and timecode and genlock.
We'll give you a simplified wiring
diagram of what a typical ICDFX studio looks like.
We'll talk about the various ports on the camera,
the SDI connections, and all the various precautions
you need to take when hooking up your camera gear.
We'll talk about timecode, the different types
and configurations, a little bit on how to jam timecode
into your camera if your camera has a particular issue.
We'll also go over genlock types and configuration
and talk about latency issues that you
might encounter when working on your ICDFX stage.
Then we'll have a section on media profiles,
in which you will learn about the setup of creating
a media profile in Unreal Engine.
And then finally, we'll have a portion
on ICDFX cinematography techniques,
where we'll talk about virtual production guidelines,
visual acuity, how to counter flicker, frame rate
and refresh issues, and a little bit
on shutter, shutter angle, shutter speed,
and how to handle Moir and Moir mitigation.
That concludes the training outline for today.
Let's get into hardware configuration.